sugarcoated that wasn't just a maximum
squeeze in a gamesmanship way uh no he
was playing for a win there in case you
forgot and he was briefly winning
according to the eval bar if he had
moved the Knight to F2 but that ship has
sailed and they repeat an opening that
we saw quite a bit in the three-minute
portion a sicilian with a bishop on C3 I
don't love the way this starts for
Hikaru I mean Magnus just seems to have
gotten a very very nice setup here yep
yep A3 and C3 you can see the
desperation to get that Bishop back to
C3 yeah get rid of that pawn Magnus and
Magnus says no I will
not Bishop E3 I mean again hoping to
have B take C3 played I I still feel
like um Magnus is really really happy
with how this is started but he's got to
figure out a way to protect the D7 Pawn
either directly or indirectly as he's
done now he can castle look at this
tactical awareness of on Queen takes D7
Rook d8 traps the queen that's such a
hard idea to see in bullet and it was
was because of Queen B8 covering the the
C7 Square so he totally planned that I
would put the queen on C7 though to give
the Rook a little bit more latitude
along the eighth rank maybe later you
can play Rook A8 Magnus burning a lot of
clock here and this is what he was
spending it on what a sacrifice and E4
is hanging the B3 Bishop is under Fire
he Caro's got to be really careful to
keep his position together here yeah
maybe okay yeah this is probably more
what Magnus was looking for two Bishops
imbalanced Pawn structure don't take
with a knight don't take with a knight
Bishop A4 wins the piece andaru sees
it yeah but this is fantastic for the
Bishops right it's exactly what you want
Magnus this is precisely the kind of
position that we're used to seeing him
winning regularly E5 Bishop
C6 yeah Knight B5 Bishop C6 Knight F3
you could just take it I think
that's oh he wants to play the Bishops
cuz there was one school of thought you
know just take take Rook takes B3 but
maybe that position is just objectively
very hard to win well Magnus wants to
take hearo to school in this end game
and I think he thinks Aman that you can
win the B3 Pawn on demand so he wants to
extract more out of the position maybe
milk White's clock down but he's milking
his own clock down as a
result F5
F4 okay he's going to just defend for
now but going very aggressive now Magnus
has over pressed before and he's over
pressed again or has he because Bishop
after runs into Rook A1 but there's the
move B4 and hearu missed it B4 would
have kept the C5 Pawn defended now it
should be technically winning for
Carlson M he keeps the Rooks on I don't
know whether that was a a chance to to
trade it off I I think hear made the
right choice though D5 now is going to
come with devastating effect look at
Black's Pawn failinks not over yet
though yaru Rook is very very active and
if you push your pawns prematurely
Bishop
D4 wow is he just going to try to like
stay in this position is okay he's
giving H7 and Rook A6 there's Rook B6
and that spells
trouble but is this
winning it
is that was quick it is but not easy
look ataru using every last resource but
he's just not fast enough King C2
now oo yeah Bishop E3 and Bish G
remember there's like this H Pawn Bishop
configuration on the H1 Square oh D2
apparently that was wrong
E5 oh my gosh this is so close to a draw
all of a sudden
H6 amazing wow but how do you win this
you do you get your king back to G4 yeah
you Bishop C3 and now you just walk and
eventually you'll have to play G7 and
then you're playing what these two pawns
against the bishop how does that work
Aman I don't think I would have found H6
in a classical game that is inhuman to
leave the protected passer on G3 G7 and
now it's finally completely winning or
is it not but yeah yeah you really have
to work again here though this is color
Pawn but he's going to get the bishop
off I mean that win was truly insane